the island of madagascar
known for being home to the world's most
unique flora and fauna
playful lemurs colorful chameleons
stunning orchids
it's here that five castaway species
from the central park zoo will try to
make a home along the way they'll make
alliances
compete against dangerous foes and try
to overcome the elements of this
beautiful but
untamed land seven movies five animals
one survivor
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that likes to move it move it
if by move you mean destroy and it you
mean the simple nostalgic memories that
you once had of all the movies that you
watched as a child now maybe you think
that makes me a bit of a buzzkill but
just can't help thinking about the
implications of whimsical worlds created
by animated movies i suppose a
quote-unquote
normal person would watch a movie like
the rescuers and think oh that's cute
little adventure story starring two
talking mice but is it really
my fault if i watch that same movie and
think to myself huh the bottle at the
beginning of the movie is taken to a
mouse version of the united nations now
the real united nations was formed after
world war ii
so does that mean that this mouse
society also had itself a world war ii
does that mean that there was a
first world war between mice followed by
an ill-conceived mouse league of nations
that collapsed in the face of rising
mouse nationalism look if you're gonna
create a fantastical world
somebody is gonna have to ask the tough
questions about how it works and that
somebody is inevitably gonna be me and
so for today's topic
will be ruining i mean looking at what i
believe to be one of the more underrated
animated franchises of the 21st century
madagascar not only are these movies
lighthearted and fun they also feature
some really impressive voice talent no
other franchise is really going to give
you zoolander borat walter white and
jack donaghy all in the same place
they're fun
they're colorful the writing is fine
most of the time
grand central station it's grand
and it's central what was was that a
joke it seemed like it was setting up
for a joke
that just say grand central station or
my aunt's constipation
yeah okay so not all the jokes are gonna
land here but these movies are easy to
watch and they distract my toddler long
enough for me to go to the bathroom in
peace
so what's not to love but and you know
that when i start singing the praises of
a movie franchise there's gonna be some
sort of butt involved
i just can't help but wonder how well
our beloved talking animal friends are
actually gonna fare on the island of
madagascar
if you need a reminder in the first
movie alex the lion marty the zebra
mel-min the giraffe gloria the hippo and
a whole host of other animals are being
relocated from their home in the central
park zoo to a wildlife preserve
over in kenya due to the hijinks of the
penguins on board the animal crates fall
off the side of a ship and wash ashore
on the coast of you're never gonna guess
it
madagascar oh boy didn't see that one
coming and then they learn a lot of
valuable lessons about friendship and
there are some dance breaks and we leave
the door wide open for a subsequent
series of sequels all in under 90
minutes
four stars it's uh no wall-e but it's
definitely not minions
so we're in the clear wood watch again
which is good considering my son is
going to want to watch it 300 more times
before the next month but of course the
crazy part of my brain can't help but
ask the question
how are these animals really gonna fare
on the island of madagascar
none of their species actually live
there in the wild and these particular
animals have grown up in a zoo with
regular meals being delivered to them
and no threat of predators around unless
of course you count that one old lady
that they met in grand central station
so today we're playing a high-stakes
version of survivor madagascar
where the losers leave the island in a
body bag
who's gonna live who's gonna die who
lives to tell your spin-off
keep your giant lemur eyes peeled for
all those pesky fossa because today
we're escaping to africa
because madagascar is part of the
continent of africa just
just go with it to start off with let's
go with our early favorite alex the lion
he's strong he's fast he dances for
people at the zoo and to be sure there
are certain things about madagascar's
landscape that alex is going to be
finding pretty appealing
for one the apex predator on madagascar
is as we see in the movie the fossa so
unlike in mainland africa where alex
would have to compete with leopards and
cheetahs and hyenas for his kills on
madagascar his biggest competition
weighs about 20 pounds
less than 1 10th of his regular size
should be a pretty easy win for him to
be king of the island right
well you see alex is far from a normal
lion
we learned from the beginning of the
sequel madagascar escaped to africa that
as a cub alex was much less interested
in learning how to fight from his father
than he is in dancing around before he's
eventually captured by poachers and ends
up in the central park zoo while his
life in that zoo
certainly gives him opportunities to
dance around the fact that he's lived
most of his life there is going to
create some problems when he's on his
own
out in the wild according to katie moore
from the international fund for animal
welfare quote
in a lot of cases it is still impossible
to release captive animals into the wild
especially if the animals have been
traumatized or were very young
when captured since lions typically live
with their mothers until they're about
two or three years old
those early years are filled with
lifelong lessons that alex never got
beyond the issues of avoiding dangerous
situations and learning the social
lessons of living in a lion pride which
itself is a moot point since there's no
other wild lions in madagascar
alex's biggest problem is the one that
we're gonna see
in the movie food a major point of the
first madagascar movie is how alex is so
used to being fed stake by
zookeepers that he doesn't really know
what to do when the gang first arrives
on the island
leading to an awkward desire to eat his
best friend marty the zebra he's calling
savage where have i heard that phrase
before i believe he
and this jaguar they they went savage
sir animals don't go
savage disney ripping off other
company's story concepts
no but in real life alex probably would
have had a hard time
even hunting marty a group called alert
the african lion and environmental
research trust has developed a procedure
for releasing previously captive lions
out into the wild and one of the most
important steps is putting the lions in
an enclosed space with prey
to give them hunting practice because
without that they're not naturally
good at hunting for their own survival
alert also usually does this with cubs
instead of the previously captured lions
because the ones who grew up in
captivity are
already considered to be largely a lost
cause
in the movie the food problem gets
solved when other animals feed alex some
sushi but again as a mature lion
alex would never be able to support
himself fishing and even more
importantly as a big cat alex
definitely wouldn't be equipped to go
into the water and hunt fish i mean you
even see him avoiding the water when
they first land on the island so it is
without
judgment that i say that our friend alex
the lion is in trouble with no survival
skills and no other lines to show him
how to survive
alex the tribe has spoken and it says
that you're gonna starve to death
on madagascar now yes i recognize that
that's a pretty dark way to start the
episode but
that's the circle of life friends ever
watched planet earth no horror movie
i've ever seen has scarred me as badly
as seeing a
giant centipede catch a bat out of
midair and eat it
the point is nature is metal y'all it
doesn't take
any prisoners and it's not all bad news
i mean marty the zebra
doesn't have to learn how to hunt his
prey mainly because it's rooted in the
ground
and can't run away he as a zebra eats
plants and
that's not that hard to come by and
while the movie makes it seem like marty
might make for a nice fossa feast
it's actually unlikely that they try to
eat him in real life given that they
almost
always hunt alone and marty outweighs
them by approximately 800 pounds
so marty should be fine on madagascar
right plenty of food no predators
well one of the other major issues with
animals raised in captivity is that they
become habituated to humans
and don't fear them after they get
re-released into the wild ac
that's gonna be especially dangerous for
marty in madagascar for marty
humans have represented safety and food
for his whole life but once he lands in
madagascar it's very likely that any
humans he encounters will be much more
dangerous to him you see
zebras are very frequently hunted in
their native habitat
sometimes for meat but much more often
for their distinctive striped skin
and unfortunately poaching is just a
huge
problem in madagascar historically the
poachers there hunt
for lemurs so king julian will probably
want to move it move it if he sees any
humans coming but it's likely that a
non-native zebra pelt would be a
big win for the local poachers sorry
marty the tribe
has spoken next up is melman the giraffe
again
mel-min is probably too big to be prey
for any of the animals that exist on the
island
also madagascar is home to many of the
trees that giraffes like to eat from the
most there's even an initiative underway
to plant 60 million new trees on
madagascar many of which are acacia
trees which just so happens to be a
giraffe's favorite food and again we've
also seen mel-min eat a urinal cake so
being picky about
food might not have been that much of a
problem anyway
that room has some nifty little things
you can wash up and look
free but here is the problem for mel-min
we know from madagascar escape to africa
that melman is a bit of a hypochondriac
okay you guys really need a doctor and
honestly as a giraffe
he has every right to be giraffes are
especially susceptible to parasites
skin conditions and a whole variety of
other diseases oddly one disease that
giraffes
are known to get is tuberculosis and
tuberculosis is a huge
problem in madagascar the international
association for medical assistance to
travelers specifically warns that tb
is highly endemic to madagascar and a
major health problem in the country
now tb isn't always fatal but with
mel-min living on his own he isn't going
to be receiving a whole heck of a lot of
treatment beyond sitting in his own die
hole
and if the tb doesn't get melvin there's
a pretty decent chance that he'll get
himself some trypanosomosis a disease
caused by protozoan parasites and known
to infect both giraffes
and a wide variety of species on
madagascar mel-min
the tribe has spoken and it says you
should have worn a mask and gotten your
shots
okay okay but what about the penguins
huh if they can hijack the boat that was
taking all the animals to africa in the
first place then surely they should be
able to manage surviving in madagascar
right well
canonically speaking the penguins are
adelie penguins one of the few species
of penguins that actually lives
in antarctica now you might not believe
this but the climates of antarctica
and a subtropical island off the coast
of africa
are going to be just a wee bit different
in coastal regions like the one where
our little feathered friends land
temperatures get up to around 32
degrees celsius 90 degrees fahrenheit
adelie penguins have to remain
constantly in cold temperatures
otherwise they faint like little pokemon
now while i wasn't able to find exact
data on what kind of temperatures cause
a deli penguins to faint uh
permanently it's reasonable to assume
that their temperature tolerance is
gonna be similar to that of the emperor
penguin
the only other species to live its
entire life on antarctica
emperor penguins start to eat snow in
order to regulate their body
temperatures when they overheat
and the high end of temperatures that
they can withstand is about
68 degrees fahrenheit 20 degrees celsius
a good
33 plus cooler than the temperatures
that they'll be experiencing on
madagascar
sorry penguins you can't macgyver your
way out of heat stroke the tribe
has spoken now at this point you're
probably thinking to yourself man
i should probably subscribe to this
channel and you know what i'm thinking
man that is a really good idea help us
get that much closer to 10 million
subscribers on film theory i would
appreciate it but after you've clicked
the red button below this video as well
as rung the bell i'm sure your next
thought is disappointment you clicked on
this video because you like the
madagascar movies so you know you've
been having a grand old time listening
to me
list off the gruesome horrific deaths
awaiting these charming innocent
characters and let me just say this dear
viewer i have good news and it comes in
the form
of gloria the hippo unlike alex gloria
doesn't need to learn the finer points
of hunting from other hippopotami since
her food doesn't move hippos eat plants
the climate in madagascar is fine for
her as many hippos are native to
sub-saharan african regions with similar
even a bit
warmer climate hippos are susceptible to
a few diseases most notably anthrax but
no confirmed cases of anthrax have been
found on madagascar in recent history
sadly hippos are
sometimes targets of poachers usually
for their teeth but gloria has a better
shot against poachers than marty for
sure for one she has the option of
escaping underwater if she needs to and
also hippos routinely kill humans so
she's got herself better ability to
defend herself
than her zebra buddy now maybe you think
that i'm leading you astray to pull the
rug out from under you then i'm setting
up all the pieces to show her survival
only to cruelly rip her life away in the
most brutal fashion in the final
sentences of this video but no
not this time actually gloria actually
has a great shot of surviving we have
real world evidence that a hippopotamus
raised in captivity could
in fact be released into an environment
that it's not native to and not only
survive but thrive and it comes from the
world's most
notorious drug dealer no not him this
guy
pablo escobar pablo escobar was a
notorious colombian drug lord famous for
a variety
of things perhaps the most wholesome of
which was that he had himself a private
zoo when he was killed in 1993 his four
pet hippos were released into the wilds
of colombia and wouldn't you know it
there aren't four hippos there anymore
there are now
as many as a hundred in colombia's
magdalena river they adapted to the
environment the vegetation
the whole ecosystem of an entirely
different continent than the one that
they came from
so when gloria finds herself on
madagascar she
unlike her comrades is well equipped to
stay for the long haul after a while she
might just take the crown away from king
julien
and if that means i don't have to see
him dance anymore i am all for it see i
told you this episode would have a happy
ending
but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and
[Music]
cuts
oh